hey folks my name is jake host and
producer of gamespot after dark
gamespot's official video game podcast
what you're about to watch is a clip
from the most recent episode if you want
to hear the full thing just look for
gamespot after dark on the podcast
platform of your choice
in this video jean-luc shares his
experience with monster hunter ryze
after around 30 hours
if you enjoyed this make sure to like
and subscribe because all that really
helps us out
anyway let's get to it well jean-luc
you've probably been
playing one of the biggest games of the
year so far that is
monster hunter rise how have you been
have you been doing with it
i i think it's fantastic it's uh i feel
like i should
people always like ask like well what's
your monster hunter credibility
it's like one of those weird franchises
whip your monster peen out
because it's been around for so long and
and um
uh i i unfortunately have only played um
world i tried to get into um
generations ultimate on the switch and
uh i just couldn't get into it like
mechanically it it's
yeah so uh there's so many quality of
life things that world made that i was
just like i
can't get into this i'm sure it's great
i respect the people who who
love it um rise however
is builds off of world and
and so all the things that i think like
world did great that
um it continues with so it has a lot of
the like the quality life stuff
being able to uh like pick up items as
you move
um just like the the fluidity of the
animation
um and the nice thing about it compared
to
world is that because it's it's
technically not the same engine it's
actually
uh i think world was using empty
framework and this is using the re
engine
but um one of the complaints about world
was that
because they had to rebuild it for uh
hd there weren't as many monsters um i
forget the total
like count in world but uh generations
ultimately had like 90 plus
so a lot of people were like this isn't
enough monsters to hunt
this is this is [ __ ] even though
like i played it and i was like oh i
thought it was pretty good
i i uh but this is like feels more
substantial where it's like okay they
brought everything in from world
and then are just adding more on top of
it
also this game is uh japanese
inspired in its setting which is
fantastic and in my opinion way more
interesting than like the weird
new world colonizer vibes of
monster hunter like it was fine but it
was a little like okay it's like
sure we're like in a new world and
whatever and this is like
uh all the monsters are inspired by like
yokai
so you're like this is great and then
like every introduction is a cut scene
where there's like a poem
about each uh monster they're very
cheesy but they're like
it's very i love that because it's like
really really like poetic and they're
like now smash this thing today
uh so i just i love the vibes the
soundtrack oh the soundtrack is
oh absolute banger just like
wall-to-wall like everything in it is so
good
or sequence title sequence the title
screen it's like
capcom when they do title screens they
do take good like
they do it's it's dragon's dogma kind of
like i'm just gonna let this title
screen rock for a bit
because i turned it on for the first
time and i was like i just
sing to me nice lady that's very nice
it's like soothing
it's like doing panning and she's like
sitting down and doing like this really
heartfelt song i was like
i love this i don't want to play this
anymore
you know smash a monster to death smash
monster to death
uh but yeah it's like i i think they
just
they make so many little changes that i
think for me
makes it uh more enjoyable than world
specifically i think because it's on
handheld they
they kind of have to like streamline
some of the processes so like in world
they had this like it's hd so we have
this like big hub
and you're kind of like walking upstairs
and going to these multiple locations
and there's like an elevator you take
and it's cool
but after a while you're like i just
need to quickly get to the cantina
i don't want to walk i don't care about
this anymore
because it's on switch the hub is super
confined
you can just instantly fast travel to
anywhere and it's like instantaneous so
if you everything feels snappier in the
game it feels like you can just get to
where you need to go
to get what you want so you can get back
to the next fight so everything just
feels
like really really uh immediate in a way
that
i think is like more beneficial to the
game like it's not
trying to impress you as much with the
visual so you can just focus more on
on the fighting um and then the fighting
itself i feel like they've made a couple
of really
smart additions um the first being
the or the biggest being the wireframe
which or a wire bug
which basically is like a grappling hook
uh that you can use both in traversal
and in fights
in the traversal it's great because it
allows you to like
ninja run your way on walls um and up
terrain
and when you first play it you you look
at the map and you're like oh okay i
have these like basic lanes that i'm
following
to get to the monsters uh but what you
kind of don't realize is that
you can basically go anywhere you want
using the wire bug
and when you get really good at it you
can like chain the wire bug and
essentially like
just parkour your way up like a mountain
if you want to and then that can get you
to like different um
vantage point so you can get to like
certain special rare resources so
there's like a sense of verticality that
um
they've added with it that i think just
like makes
running around really fun in a way where
because like world had that verticality
too
but it kind of sucked because if you
were like fighting a monster at like the
top of like a tree and you get knocked
off you're like okay
i gotta spend five minutes walking my
way back up
this like a monster knocked me off in
like mid air i like grappled back onto
the ledge and just like got myself back
up and it felt
super satisfying the amount of times in
worlds where i've been like
running away from a monster and forget
that there's a ledge there and like
turned the camera at the last second to
see that i was [ __ ] as a legendary and
my hunter is like
it's too late buddy we're leaping off
this and i'm just like oh
that's like oh my god it's got like the
wire the wire bug stuff
it's got big like uh bionic commando
vibes for me oh yeah
i'm playing it i'm just like this is
bionic commando once on and i'm very
interested
it's really good it's super fun and and
then it also comes into the combat where
you can use it to do like certain combos
and
they um have like unique compost for
each weapon
that uh uh you can then even like go and
trade them out you unlock like new
combos as you go so like
it's just like all of the complexity of
world and then they've just like
layered even more on it um although i
feel like it's not
complex enough where it's hard to
understand
in well yes and no i would say it still
has that monster hunter problem where
like
if it's your first time playing it
you're probably gonna be like pretty
confused and the tutorials aren't
the best but
compared to something like generations
ultimate where i tried going from world
to that and i was like i have no idea
this is like building off of like
you know three 3ds games worth of like
mechanics and i have no idea what i'm
doing this feels like a more natural
uh step from world to jump into and and
i would actually recommend it
um even if you haven't played world
because i think just the portability
nature of it
it's so easy to like pick up and try
how's the multiplayer i don't know if
you have a chance because i know the
servers
have been on and off a little bit uh
have you experienced that at all
yeah no i was able to play a little bit
of the multiplayer
when it was up um for like press people
it apparent ben was telling me benjamin
was telling me it's apparently using
like
nintendo's new online like networking
uh like like they have like a new way
that they like
network and and this is going to be like
the premier game that shows it off
uh granted it was a preview environment
so i can't speak to like the
you know public experience but it was
instantaneous like i
went to a lobby um found friends and
said all right let's play together
within seconds we were just like in the
same match and then we were able to just
join instantly hadn't i hope that
continues
awesome did they sacrifice to the devil
to make that happen
there's not enough probably there's
gotta be some like downside to this
because i've never tried nintendo and
internet
come on so but what about just the act
of like getting into games with
friends and and going back to the hub
because i remember that was one really
weird thing about monster hunter world
and i know
people who play the old ones said it was
improved but still i remember
i think specifically like trying to play
co-op story was super strange
in world i think like you couldn't
you couldn't do cutscenes so like in
world they had this thing where
if one player hadn't seen a cut scene
they couldn't join until like after the
cutscene had triggered because like you
could walk around and find the monster
and so you basically play with a friend
be like okay you join the match or you
you start up the match
let the cutscene tell us when the cut
scene's over and then we'll join you and
it's super annoying
this doesn't have that problem because
one there aren't any like cutscenes that
play
during the match they just play like
before um
and they're all pre-rendered so it
doesn't have that problem on top of that
they have separated the single player
and the multiplayer missions
uh from each other so there's like
village missions and there's hub
missions and the village missions which
is the
story mode although it's pretty minimal
compared to world there isn't really
much of a story
uh compared to that game uh but you
can't you can only do those
single-player
so then like the hub stuff you can you
could do the hub stuff single player if
you want but it's meant for co-op
so there isn't any of those restrictions
anymore
it's also really easy to uh
join you can set up like lobby
parameters they have the id system which
they've had in like world you can also
just pull up your friends list and just
like instantly join them
so it feels a lot they've definitely
learned a lot of lessons from the
multiplayer
also like i said because the hub is is a
lot smaller and more condensed it's like
way easier to just like
go to the like multiplayer room um
as opposed to world where again it's
like okay i gotta travel all the way up
the elevator and
the cut scene's gonna play and i have to
wait and there's a long loading time
like it's
it's just snappy it felt it felt really
good to just like
immediately be able to get in and start
playing with people that's so cool i
really hope they can maintain that
energy when uh
when the game launches because like our
uh review is
as of this recording still in progress
because of the the
multiplayer question um but that is
that's really cool i know like this is
the kind of the fur
the pilot of that new online
i don't know if it's a system like i
don't know what you call it but
um that's exciting to hear i hope yes
structure
yeah i hope it rolls out to like i
wonder if they'll i hope they
retroactively put it into like
stuff like smash and america and i mean
miracast
i don't know i've had very good luck
with mario kart like it's been pretty
good
smash lesso but like um i would love to
see that stuff going
i'm just really happy there's a portable
once on her again yeah
it is it feels great it's like
i i really want everyone like if you
liked world and you have a switch like
you should absolutely play it because it
does feel like an evolution
of that game i'm super curious what like
hardcore
uh monster hunter like old school
monster under people who who didn't
like world feel about it um i guess i
don't know if like anyone disliked
well i'm sure there's somebody here yeah
i know i know a few hardcore
my brother was like not in super in the
world and he's like
he has literal thousands of hours in
various monster hunter games
okay yeah what was it specifically they
didn't like about it
i think my brother was like um
i think he's one of those people who
because we grew up playing monster
hunter from ps2
psp onwards the obtuseness
of it is kind of a a kind of a thing
like there's a language to it
yeah like when you change it and
simplify it it also
to a lot of people it it makes it
uncomplicated but to some people it's
like
you throw them for a loop and i think
that was a big part of it like
the language he'd grown to like speak
and understand the way it was formatted
and presented
and it kind of changed and i think like
the lack of monsters and the kind of
area stuff was or something that he was
like i mean like my brother was not a
maniac he wasn't on the internet
fighting people about it he was just
like i liked it but
you know it wasn't the best one for me
he's he's more okay
he he's like me where he if he's if he's
playing monster hunter he needs to be
like contorting his fingers until it's
painful and reading
dialogue and not understanding anything
okay that kind of stuff all right well
like i i've been playing more sauna for
years and i picked this one up and i'm
i've been
i'm having a fantastic time with it like
um it's a new flavor of monster hunter
and that's good
yeah yeah i think it the setting like i
said does a lot to like
separate it uh also palamutes there's
dogs in this game yeah
and they're yeah they're beautiful you
get to make a dog
at the beginning uh mine is uh a pink
dog named sakura
you get to like they're they're called
buddies so like the the palomuts and the
palikos are now
buddies and there's like a whole buddy
mechanic where you can like hire new
buddies or
you can like request uh buddies with
certain stats and then you can just go
in and like
make so you could spend you could
literally i think you have like 12 or 16
slots
if you wanted you could individually
customize the look of all 16 of your
buddies
and just never actually play the game i
have a i have a really cool
white dog named nina oh
uh but the button oh no
oh wait oh i just realized
i got god i got caught
i was just like oh that's cute that was
probably the name of tam's dog or
no
how long do you see yourself playing
this game do you think you'll be
spending
a lot more time with it or do you feel
like you've kind of gotten your fill of
it
during this preview experience i'll
definitely play more i've put about
30 hours in although i'm sure like five
of that was just like leaving my switch
on
um but i'm gonna boost those numbers
i feel like i'm still pretty early uh
like i i got like the first
credits but it like that doesn't really
mean anything cause i think there's like
there's still way more story to do um
and then i've like
only got to do a little bit of like the
multiplayer hub stuff so
um at the like i'm not the kind of
person who would probably
just like play for thousands of hours
and try and get like my my monster
hunter rank score up but
at the very least i want to fight every
monster and you know
make a couple of the cool sets that i
want to make and and
so i'm definitely i'll probably put in
at least another
30 hours i bet
you